- Health officials in China are trying to
identify a mysterious strain of pneumonia.
- [Reporter] China, ordering a quarantine
for the entire city of Wuhan,
where the contagious coronavirus was first
detected and is spreading fast.
Detected or suspected in at least 11
countries across the globe,
concerns of a global pandemic are spreading from
a virus that’s now reached the United States.
- A Washington state man has died
from coronavirus, the first death
from that disease here in the U.S.
- [Reporter] The NBA is now urging its
players to avoid high-fiving fans.
- [Reporter] Major event organizers and
cities face the difficult choice of
whether to cancel big public events.
- [Reporter] The NBA is telling teams they
should be prepared for the possibility
of playing games in empty arenas.
- [Reporter] The teams insist that
they won’t play without fans.
- If I show up to an arena and ain’t
no fans in there, I ain’t playing.
- I mean you just gotta be prepared
for anything, and at the same time,
keep living, keep doing what we do.
- NBA, MLB, NHL, MLS banning all
nonessential personnel from their
locker rooms until further notice.
- [Reporter] Golden State Warriors
confirming they will play
without fans tomorrow night.
March Madness will also be
closed to the general public.
- [Reporter] Today, the World
Health Organization officially
calling it a pandemic.
- Just a regular road trip.
Rudy and I, we generally sit
across the aisle from each other.
Royce, Emmanuel and Bojan behind me,
and then Mike behind Rayjon Tucker.
Got there the night before.
We were pretty excited for
this game, just ready to go.
We knew Rudy was gonna
be out for the game.
He’s, you know, feeling a little bit sick.
We get to the game.
We warm up.
Everything is going real smooth,
and next thing you know, you see
a bunch of guys in suits run out.
I thought it was the FBI.
- You knew something was going on as
soon as you looked out on the court.
I was two rows from the court.
You saw people that you usually don’t
see during that time of the game.
You saw the Thunder’s assistant
general manager talking to officials.
Their team doctor, Donnie Strack,
who was also talking to officials.
- There was so much confusion, so many
little red flags as an NBA reporter that
said something is different and wrong.
- I got a call from the league office.
Fans were in the seats, ready to go.
We were now five or 10 minutes past
the point we were supposed to tip.
- I’ve been part of game delays before.
There was, like, a leak
coming out of the ceiling.
So it really felt like that, outside
of the guys rushing the floor.
We were just told we just gotta go back.
I walked back thinking, “All right,
we’ll be back out in, like, 45 minutes.”
- At first we’d heard from an Oklahoma
City television reporter that law
enforcement was on their way to the
arena to help evacuate, and so our first
indication was, “Is this a bomb threat?”
- Then we got to the locker room.
We were told Rudy had it, and at that
point, we were kinda just silent.
That’s when it became scary.
- Due to unforeseen circumstances,
the game tonight has been postponed.
You are all safe.
Thank you for coming out tonight.
Good night, fans.
- Our Shams Charania at The Athletic
actually broke the news that
Rudy Gobert had coronavirus.
- In that moment, we made the decision
we should be taking a hiatus.
- There was no hesitation.
There was no call to
the Board of Governors.
There was no consultation with anybody.
Adam Silver just shut the league down.
- This is crazy.
This can’t be true.
I mean, it’s not within
the realm of possibilities.
It’s just a scene more like
out of a movie than reality.
- I honestly thought we were gonna be
like, “All right, we’re going back to the hotel.”
Then come to find out the hotel
that we stayed at was under lockdown.
No hotels would take us.
- We’re sitting down, kind of
outside the door where the players
leave, and you’re seeing health
officials come through with boxes.
- When I saw them come in with their
suits and equipment and masks, the
stuff we see today, you’re like, “All
right, this is, like, the real deal.”
- The reporters that travel and cover
the team, we’re in direct contact
with these players all the time.
We’re in very close proximity,
talking right next to their faces.
They got us all tested, including
the team and the traveling party, and
left the arena a little after 1 a.m.
- I slept about 20 minutes that whole night.
8:30 the next morning, that’s
when I found out that I had it.
One of the scariest
experiences of my life.
My biggest concern was I had
just seen my mother and my sister
four or five days before that.
And I called them like, “Look, you
have to get tested right away.”
I went back home, and I had to
separate myself from my family.
I’m in the basement by myself, and
I have no windows in my basement.
You don’t know if it’s 4 p.m.
or 4 a.m.
It’s Monday.
Will it come on Tuesday?
Tuesday, temperature’s the same.
Will it come on Wednesday?
Wednesday, will it come on Thursday?
And I was down there
for about 10, 11 days.
At the end of the day, I’m 23.
You know, I’m a kid,
and I still have fears.
Obviously having the virus, I feel
a certain—a different way than most.
I wish people understood
a little bit more.
- Once the NBA shut down, it felt like
the first domino had fallen, and it was
just a matter of time for every other
domino to start falling, for the leagues
to start saying, “This is not safe.”
- March Madness, one of the greatest
spectacles in all of sports, has
been knocked out, and the four
major professional sports leagues
in North America have been silenced.
For how long is anyone’s guess.
- The season just began off-kilter.
The tweet by the Rockets’ GM about
the protesters in Hong Kong,
and then we mourn the loss of David
Stern, the former commissioner.
And then on that Sunday, when we got the
news on Kobe, it was…you’re just empty.
- So people were already kind of
in this emotional vortex and this
emotional conflict when all of a
sudden, boom, here’s a pandemic.
I don’t think the gravity hit
the players until there was the
first positive test in the NBA.
It was just a really grave
wakeup call about what we were
about to be confronted with.
And then for that to be compounded
by then having unprecedented level of
racial conversations as we’re talking
about police violence and institutional
racism and systemic oppression.
In this situation where my humanity
is at stake, where the humanity of
my people is at stake, do I want
to be the entertainment right now?
I think a big reason why this entire
conversation that we’re having in this
country is at the level that it is is
because there has been no sports to
distract anybody, is because we have
no choice but to sit here and reflect.
- We have a moment in time.
People are gonna look back, our
kids are gonna look back at this
and say, “You were a part of that.”
I’m glad it’s something that’s sparked
a newer conversation of having athletes
lead the charge, having athletes
that are not just basketball players,
but that can, you know, lead and
speak on the issue intelligently.
- March 11 is the night that
changed the world forever.
I don’t think it’s just basketball.
I think it stopped the
world in its tracks.
It stopped our country in its tracks.
- Your love of team and your love of sport
and the game you’ve always played is
colliding with your love of family and
your love of spouse and what’s best.
And there’s not an easy answer in there.
I don’t know if we’re gonna see games
played the way we’ve always seen games
played with 20,000 screaming fans.
Is sports ever gonna be the same?
If I told you I knew that
answer, I’d be lying to you.